you
[Music]
I think the main single point I want to
emphasize is don't think about jobs
think about well-being and think about
what kind of well-being results from
this technology one of the things that
should result from this technology is
more leisure time and more time to do
creative things that right now are not
classified as compensated work and
that's good and what we're interested in
is well-being and the distribution of
well-being and those raise lots of
complicated questions but framing
everything as the number of jobs is the
wrong way to think about this now let's
go back if we were the horses in 1900
and we saw the car coming but the only
difference to Erick story is suppose the
horses were in charge oh and not even on
thank you oh and off my crown okay but
you can't turn it off again your fileted
to me for 20 minutes suppose we do
suppose we were the horses in 1900 but
we were in charge I think we could view
this as a wonderful opportunity not as a
collapse but for the chance for all of
those new trucks and automobiles to
carry the heavy loads and we go to
Central Park and graze all day and maybe
our jobs would Olli but if we owned the
cars in the trucks our well-being would
certainly soar and so the idea that a
decline of the jobs is really the right
metric is not appropriate for that
little parable that Eric gave us and I
think it's not appropriate for this
technology more generally probably the
best starting point in the literature is
nineteen twenty and that's topic are you
are we're awesomes Universal robots
because his world was the world in which
the robots did everything
and I think that's a good limiting
condition for us to think about would
that be a disastrous world would that be
a good world what kind of world would it
be because if you guys are as good as I
think you are that's the kind of world
that can evolve over time and where the
robots do a lot of the heavy lifting as
it were and we have time as human beings
to do other things that are not the
drugs work that has been the fact of
most of humanity for most of history at
least since the end of hunting and
gathering ten thousand years ago and the
advent of Agriculture which is a lot of
drudgery and which is how most of
humanity lived for most of most of our
species
modern history now for me there have
been three great trends of modern
economic growth which is roughly since
1800 and AI is not a break in that it's
a continuation because we've had smarter
and smarter machines for the last 200
years and there have been three basic
realities that have come from that one
is that the share of national income
earned by capital has risen
significantly over time sometimes we
don't see that so starkly in the data
because part of capital is human capital
it's the returns to the investment in
skills but if you add up the returns to
the investment in skills plus the
returns to physical capital and look at
what's left over for raw labor the share
of the output that's going to raw labor
has declined significantly and
consistently for 200 years that's likely
to continue in fact one thing that a I
might do is significantly shift the
returns from human capital to physical
capital because the machines are going
to do what smart people do right now or
well-trained people do right now and
that will be an added shift but it will
be a shift within capital and there will
be a continuing shift
away from labor and I think that that is
a 200 year trend that's going to
continue
second is people actually don't like to
work hard physical labor that's partly
from introspection I might say but it
also seems to be a general principle and
essentially we used to work 20-hour work
weeks about 40,000 to 10,000 years ago
in hunting and gathering which by all
estimates is not a very arduous job then
came agriculture agriculture raised the
work time to essentially year-round
back-breaking labor it's really tough
and for the next nine thousand eight
hundred years or so and being a little
bit facetious but roughly that span
people worked all the time in physical
daytime from the earliest morning till
basically late in the evening when the
Sun went down the lights went out it was
the end of the feasible workday very
very difficult work and even you look in
the United States in 1900 most workers
were still manual labor and they were
working officially 70 hour work weeks or
women who were not formally in the labor
force were working even harder at home
with the people with the fuel with the
water with the clothing with the sewing
with the very heavy physical labor as
well on the farm and that was life life
was very very hard work I don't know
about you but I don't I barely do any
work in that sense most of my life is
just consumption like today it's
classified under a phoney category
called work but I'm having the time of
my life I'm not breaking a sweat
what's my normal work day I go to
Starbucks I meet somebody I meet someone
else at lunch
I have another meeting this is work they
pay you for that by the way but not
necessarily on a market basis because
I'm paid by a university which is not a
market based institution it gets money
from taxes and it gets money from
philanthropy I have no idea what my true
market value is my market value
that's not my human value by the way
that's a big difference to think about
the difference for the human value and a
market value they're very very different
things my market value is less than my
salary in the sense that I'm funded by
force by taxes or unfunded by gifts I'm
not funded by the products they sell but
anyway the point I was trying to make is
that what I call work or what's labeled
for most of our work is fun and it's not
hard and it is not physical exertion and
it's a lot of leisure and most of our
time people could only dream in other
parts of the world where I work as a
development economist of a life like
this because they are working round the
clock to stay alive to be able to have
the funds to eat to be able to have the
funds to go to a doctor if they need it
our lives are nothing like that we're
already in leisure but it's categorized
somewhat differently but I'm going to
show you some numbers about the amount
of leisure that we have and I think it's
just going to continue and the third ah
done that's clever
an economist one two and two there you
go you can take everything with that
credibility afterward and that is the
remarkable decline of manual labor in in
the economy so my guest from 1900 rough
estimate about 70 percent of the
American labor force was working
physical labor
that's farm labor or carrying things or
stevedores or construction workers and
now our mining sector now it's well
under 10% arguably six or seven percent
manufacture construction is about 5%
mining is a half a one-percent
agriculture and by the way today's
farmers most of them don't farm they sit
on their tractor I recently talked to a
farmer he's got smart autonomous tractor
driving he says I still like to go sit
on the tractor
I fit backwards I watched the fields
from behind but the tractor does
everything it puts on the fertilizer it
puts in the seed the physical labor is
gone thank goodness it's horrible by the
way if you work in agricultural settings
people are breaking their backs trying
to stay alive and our farmers who are
less than 1% of our population now have
very little most of them or many of them
had very little physical labor and of
course white-collar as a this is just up
to 2000 60% we're roughly at 70 75 80
percent of what might be called clerical
or sales it's not all fancy jobs but
it's what's classified under
white-collar work on a given day the
average American adult is that let's not
even say adult it's Americans over the
age of 16 work 3 hours 10 minutes
I find this thrilling and stunning by
the way our society is so productive
that 3 hours 10 minutes does it for
$55,000 average per capita income can
you imagine how good our technology is
thanks to you and thanks to two
centuries of advance we can support the
American economy with the average 16
plus year old working 3 hours 10 minutes
as opposed to what probably was an
average by this measure seven and a half
eight hours maybe 80% of 16 plus worked
in 1900 very few retirees
most kids not at school and now today
only 42% of 16-plus are at work on any
given day because kids are in school
people are in retirement people are on
vacation or leave time people are
caregiving in their families of course
some are in incarceration unfortunately
especially in the United States a few
are in unemployment but basically our
society is so sophisticated that we can
support an unimaginably high level of
living us enjoying ourselves today not
breaking a sweat at all all being flown
in on someone's tab having wonderful
gala dinners all of this stuff we can
support this with 3 hours 10 minutes of
work on average and so I guess that work
has declined by more than 50% and if you
count what I would say is real work
which is breaking a sweat it's declined
a lot more than 50% over the past
century and I mention all of this
because AI is going to do this you know
is going to accelerate this fundamental
underlying trend so these are huge gains
in well-being that's the key point
however you score them on jobs not jobs
leisure but most of the discussion
today's then how are we going to find
the jobs we should think about how are
we going to share the well-being so that
other people can sit at wonderful
conferences have good snacks have a gala
dinner talk about things that are
interesting to them maybe the baseball
scores or something else and do whatever
they want to do and share that same
amount of time meanwhile the robots will
be doing the work and that's what we
want we don't think it's a tragedy that
people aren't down in the mines anymore
as long as there's some way that they're
also enjoying a good life and for an
economist that's not hard
to think about because for me we have a
twenty trillion dollar economy and so if
someone's not working it just as a
matter that Rex Tillerson really doesn't
need a hundred eighty million dollar
severance pay he could take a little bit
less and let a miner have a day off so
if there's a little bit of distribution
in humanity in our country which
admittedly may be the hardest problem of
all it's not so hard to share the
well-being that's created by all this
technology but what I can tell you in
history is every major technological
change has expanded the pie and changed
the income distribution vote and the
idea that every major technological
change lifts everybody is always wrong
it's never been like that that's why the
Luddites trying to smash the machines
and don't think that the cotton pickers
were made better off by the cotton gin
they had to make a terrible difficult
migration north to try desperately to
find jobs especially being
african-americans it wasn't such a treat
they were hurt by the technological
advance though the overall size of the
economy increased what we forget in our
country is distribution we just hate the
very idea of it because we're mean by
the way and because what's taken as
ethics is a rant
come on no honest-to-god could we get
out of second grade what is ethics what
I want to do you know really for at
least even the paleo ethics was much
better than that and so we've just got
to grow up a little bit we have no
shortage of problems we want the pie to
expand and then we face these problems
there will absolutely be unskilled low
unemployment of low-skilled workers they
will not all become computer programmers
and by the way if you're doing your job
code will be written by code not by you
if you guys don't put yourself out of
the business something is rotten because
the computers can write better code than
you can eventually and so it's not that
everyone should be coder for heaven's
sake I don't know how anything works
that I'm dealing with anymore I don't
know how the PowerPoint works I don't
know how the computer works I don't know
how my phone works I don't know how the
plane flies that's fine
and then I try a little bit but not in
any deep way and I like that being part
of these technology systems that allow
me not have to do any work get a
paycheck have good snacks all the time
and meet interesting people which I take
to be the end goal of all of this living
living in a good society with little
work effort and plenty of time for our
creative ideas plenty of time for our
humanity and so on I had this I finally
figured it out when we went to room to
park a couple of years ago to visit the
gorillas and there you see really what
Eden was like because Adam did not go to
work in the morning and the gorillas by
the way they sit around all day
the food's right there they have sex
when they want and the kids are kind of
around but you can chew them away when
you want to and that's as close to
eating as I think we're going to get
actually and a I could bring a lot of
this along so it's not how many jobs we
can create it's how much well-being we
can really create now the problems are
there will be unemployment they will not
be compensated by becoming coders there
will be rising income equality equality
on a market basis and I'll show you a
few thoughts about that in a moment and
there are side effects because that's
not the kind of world that we actually
evolved even biologically
we're living in a very different world
so when we became sedentary which is a
good thing because we hate hard work
really I think it's the biggest thing
that humanity wants to escape is arduous
physical labor that's my observation
from 40 years of being a development
economist it's a worldwide compulsion I
want to get out of agriculture if I can
but it's part of the obesity epidemic
for example you have to recalibrate so
that when you're not moving around
you're not eating as much and this is
not you know this has been part of our
unanticipated side effects so what do we
see in macro data we see now a declining
share of Labor this is like the demand
curve for raw labour shifting left we
would say in other words a decline at
any given wage for the amount of workers
I think what Ray Kurzweil said this
morning absolutely always has to be kept
in mind though any attempt to measure
the well-being by the real income is oh
is as good as the estimate of the price
level of the services that are being
bought and I'm I'm convinced that we
have an accelerated Mis measurement of
services because we I mean of the
economy because of this very large be
materialized service sector so in this
argument with Bob Gordon and so forth
are we really growing as slowly as the
data show I think absolutely not we're
just we don't know how to measure any
outputs anymore in the service sector
outputs are measured by inputs you
absolutely don't measure productivity
how do you measure that everybody has
GPS or everybody can call each other's
friends or everybody can listen to as
much music as they want or see a movie
whenever they want it or any of that
none of that's in the price index none
of it so we don't have any sense of the
real real well-being but we do have
sense of relative shifts and raw labor
is getting the raw deal for sure because
machines are smart and they can do
better what
heavy-lifting used to be able to do but
that's all good because heavy lifting is
not fun for Humanity it's when we were
cast out of Eden that the toil by the
sweat of our brow started not within
Eden so we don't want that we want to be
rid of it but it does mean a turn of the
income distribution but I think it's
much sharper than the official data show
because the official data show labor and
capital but labour has two pieces to it
the returns to skills and the returns to
raw heavy work and the skills part we
invest heavily in by many percent of GDP
and investment in education so that's a
return to capital human capital but our
national accounts don't distinguish
human capital physical capital and raw
labour if they did I think it would look
like this
in 1900's this is made up data just by
me but it's an it's an eyeball I just
want you to know that it's an eyeball
heuristic okay so I think in 1980 guests
believe me over educated guess in 1900
I'd say half of the national income was
labour
half was physical capital and half and
third quarter physical capital and a
quarter was human capital I say today
even though we say that roughly Oh 60%
is labour 40% is capital of the part
that is labour maybe roughly half and
half is human capital raw labour so the
amount of raw labour has gone down from
maybe 50 percent to 30 percent of
national income we're not done with the
role of raw labour yet and human capital
and physical capital make up the
difference roughly and so it's some
picture like that and I would say by
2050 it will look something like this
which is the green is the raw labour and
the blue is a shrinking share of human
capital because I'm counting on you to
put me out of work because I actually
believe that
a I will be better economists than
economists because it's really hard to
track all the data it's really hard to
know what's happening in every labor
market in every micro economy it's
impossible to read the 10000 journals
except if your artificial intelligence
so I'll be happy to help train a robot
to put me out of work
I want my paycheck though so I'm coming
back to that in a moment
but I think you could get better
economic services seriously with fewer
Economist's and better expert systems in
the future and I think that that's true
of most human capital professions as
well and so the returns to income are
going to be I call a physical capital
but what I mean is the machines I don't
mean physical in the I mean physical
plus software I mean smart machines as
being the red and I think that that's
the trend that is likely to continue and
if it went to topics way it would be all
red by the time that you have the really
really smart machines in the end and
that would be ok also as long as the
machines are doing what we want them to
do to improve to keep the quality of
life expand the PI produced the food
help us with our transport and our
mobility have our virtual experiences
and essentially be able to sit in the
coffee shop and meet friends all day
which again to my mind is the ultimate
of happiness so if you look at one
sector where this is most advanced in
manufacturing of course it's the
automotive sector and there even in the
official measurements of the shift
towards capital this is the labor share
of income which back in the late 80s was
about 70% of the value-added of the
motor vehicle sector and now it's under
45% of the motor vehicle sector so by
the way as many calls as Trump makes to
God knows which automobile company
forget it are you kidding so the plants
that he just saved afford it's a seven
hundred million dollar in
meant for 700 jobs supposedly and don't
even expect all 700 jobs that must be
patted for the headlines
who puts workers in auto factories
anymore why would you so that's what's
showing here these are production
workers in this category of labour these
are all of the designers and and other
things that are working with CAD cam to
produce the models but the production
workers are basically disappeared and
the other part of this of course is the
soaring income at the top there's a lot
to be said about this but the the black
line is the famous top 1% of sizes and
tickity and that's where we've seen this
extraordinary rise of inequality and
basically what that is actually is
capital income that's the returns to
capital because capital is incredibly
unequally owned and so labor income is
being degraded by technological change
as I keep saying that's fine as long as
we redistribute the benefits but of
course we're not redistributing the
benefits this is the joke of our
politics greed Trump's if I could coin a
phrase and mr. Trump has appointed a
cabinet of billionaires and they're not
thinking what we're thinking by the way
they're thinking about how to cut the
wealth tax how to cut the estate tax I
mean how to cut the corporate tax how to
cut every tax they can think of because
that's their mania is to avoid any
redistribution that's the whole mania of
America's insatiably greedy elite and
the technology is pushing us more and
more in that direction
the tax is great because it's expanding
the pie and making us able to live
better and if you're like us because
we're all in the top 1% basically even
if you don't know it we are essentially
our lives could not
be more at least I think I don't mean
under your all your personal issues but
I mean on the economic issues it's hard
to imagine a better life more secure
never breaking a sweat having fun doing
what you want and having plenty of
leisure time under the category of work
so this is rebounding remarkably to the
very top of the income distribution
now as AI advances the returns to human
and physical capital will rise I think
because you're so good at what you're
doing the returns to capital think of it
financial but I mean the ability to buy
the robots and the AI systems that will
continue to rise the returns to lots of
human capital will fall lawyers will not
make what they used to make radiologists
may not exist in 20 years
what's a radiologist to do I'm sure you
can program these image readers to do
better job than the radiologists because
what is radiology it's pattern
recognition it's not some interpersonal
contact it's interpersonal contact with
the piece of vinyl so it's pure pattern
recognition so come on everybody finish
that finish that and then we won't have
radiologists which is okay we don't need
radiologists we need the images read and
if you can do that then anyone around
the world will be able to put the image
online and within five minutes they'll
be able to get a reading whether they're
in remote northern Uganda or in the
Himalayas or in New York City so this is
a wonderful opportunity and I think that
that's true for as I said economics
research it's true for a legal research
all the things that we heard about but
that doesn't mean that there are
compensating jobs it just means that
there's higher well-being a bigger pie
but you
need redistribution because if you don't
have redistribution a few dominate
everything and then the rest suffer so
third a second the returns to raw labour
diminish third the overall economy grows
with disproportionate gains by capital
owners and their children because the
huge transmission of capital is inter
vivos that parents take care of their
kids and so rich parents help their kids
I know my parents weren't rich but to
help me without it could not have done
what I did and my goal is to make sure
that my kids can sit in a coffee shop
the same way and enjoy themselves with
the knowledge that I think is
consumption knowledge not all investment
but of course to contribute to society
but we'll see what what that even means
because it might not mean through the
job at all so both the quests and inter
vivos transfers mean that capital owners
and their children are better off and
the big losers in society are the
children of the poor and the working
class and the really sad part of this
ridiculous election is that it's pure
bait-and-switch
because those are the ones that Trump
appeal to and he's got the least
conceivable interest or knowledge of
their reality at all and the policies
that we're about to hear about are
completely antithetical to what needs to
be done and the whole corporate
establishment will rise up in his eyes
saying how wonderful it is and what a
genius that he's cutting the corporate
tax rate and thank God he's cutting the
estate tax so that some farmer can pass
along his farm but what it really means
is so that all the non farmers can
billionaires can pass along their
billions to their children rather than
to ensure a broad-based well-being in
the society so I do little finger
exercises about this asking conceptually
what does it mean to move to a Capek
type a
Hannie where the robots do most of the
work and you can model that in a formal
way in what economists call an
overlapping generations framework where
every period is a generation and there's
young and there's old and the young come
into the world with their labor and
maybe what mommy and daddy give them
through the quest and then they work
they save and in their old age they
consume their wealth and they pass along
some of their wealth to their children
and you get an overlapping generational
framework that Paul Samuelson invented
back in 1957 and if in that framework
you put in robots and in period three
you realize that by period for the
robots are going to have a technological
boom and you ask what happens in this
society and in my little society I have
a few rich households and I have a lot
of working-class households the
working-class households don't give
bequests and they don't inherit the
quests the rich have the quests and they
pass along intergenerationally those
requests and what happens in period
three is that you realize that by period
for the robots are going to be much more
productive the pie is going to be bigger
but for that one generation but the
returns to labor the wages are going to
go down and so if you're a poor
fourth-generation you start getting hit
because your wages go down but if you're
a rich kid it's not booooo tasks it's be
quests if you're a rich kid in
generation for your parents have scored
it rich because their savings have been
multiplied by a booming stock market
call it doubt wente thousand and because
of the returns to capital they're okay
there
get a capital receipt either it could be
education it could be a transfer of
financial wealth but the rich kids are
going to be helped by their parents
whereas the poor kids are just going to
suffer a decline of of wages well in
this little particular simulation the
boost to from robotics revolution is
good enough to enable the poor to have
some little level of the quests they
help their kids for a couple of
generations but eventually the utility
of the poor children ends up lower than
before
the robotics revolution so the poor
households are absolutely initialized
compared to where they were before
AI came along there are no longer
requests because they're just so poor
whereas the rich end up permanently
better off because while the each young
generation comes in and it can't sell
its labor anymore because the wages are
reduced every generation receives a
transfer payment from the rich parents
and that goes on intergenerationally ad
infinitum so a bottom line in order for
all parts of society to benefit from
advancing technologies we need to tax
the capital owners and redistribute the
earnings to the young through free
tuition for skill training or tax
credits pay for low-wage workers without
such transfers income inequality will
rise and large parts of society will be
amiss Erised
so unless we have capital transfers even
though the pie is expanded a significant
part that part which sells its raw labor
or which cannot finance human capital
out of its own income levels will be
hard-hit let me stop there with that
issue and just raise three more issues
that have
seem to me to be important for the
discussion here this is just a final
slide based on this morning's discussion
that I you are the AI epistemic
community from a sociological point of
view and that means you are the expert
community that has responsibility for
communicating your field to society so I
would say that's your social role and
your sociological role you're the AI
epistemic community a lot of your the
discussions wonderful and the goal of
beneficial AI is fantastic but I think
it misses three things that I would like
to add one is the ethics discussion
should be about AI ethics in an
unethical world not just in a perfect
world I'm a development practitioner and
a policy guy the world is so nasty you
can't even believe it it's corrupt it's
nasty people are left to die it's
horrible that's humanity by the way
welcome to humanity
robots can do better but the point is
that you have to think about all the
misuses of the technology of course and
all I'm saying is that some commandments
aren't going to solve the problem of the
real unethical nature of the world so
you have an advocacy role that's more
than just making a list of good things
because the world isn't there to receive
your good things the world's nasty
that's number one second human behaviors
are not human values you cannot train
robots for ethical behavior based on
observed human behavior this is a big
mistake I think from this morning's
discussion I really don't agree with
Stuart Russell on this values are not
observed behaviors 2500 years of
ethical teaching in the East and the
West is all about the difference of
human behavior and human values and most
ethical teachings are about the hard
struggle for each of us to be good and
so there's a difference of what we do
and what we want to do and what we think
to be the good there's only one field
that really screwed this up badly and
that's economics because economics
starting in the 19th century said what
you observe is the good because just
take that take the preferences is given
this is almost insane from the point of
view of everything we know about
psychology and ethics but don't listen
to economist except me um
don't listen to economist about values
revealed preference is maybe useful for
something about estimating a market
demand curve but it's useless in terms
of trying to infer values for AI and so
that's my third point what's fascinating
for me is that your challenge actually
can help to reinvent moral thinking to
re-energize moral thinking now there's a
world of great moral thinking just I
mean again my favorite activity in life
is sitting at a coffee shop but I did
and sometimes with other people but
mainly reading Aristotle that's my true
heaven because it's just a joy to read a
brilliant thinker talk about the human
good and it's really it gives me a
physical height to do that there's so
much good learning to incorporate don't
just observe behavior let's get the
ethicist deeply engaged in this activity
because and I'll just stop here I used
to go on and on about how stupid the
trolley problem is because I said my
how long can these Ephesus worry about
this stupid artificial problem with so
many real important things to worry
about in the world but you know what the
trolley problems really about a trolley
it turns out because you've got to
program the self-driving vehicles so
it's actually an important problem thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]